[موسيقى]
طلع شكه اه اوكرانيا لديها كل الحق في
الوجود وهذه الحرب شنها الجانب الروسي
وهذا اعتداء الصارخ ضد الدوله مستقله
وبلا شك تسببت هذه مشاكل جمه خاصه على
النظام
اعتقد بان هذه الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي بشكلين
اذا
خرج المعتدي الروسي من اوكرانيا
هذه الحرب الروسيه انا اعرف الرئيس بوتين
وعبر هذا البرنامج او انه اطالب الرئيس
بوتين بوضع حد لهذه الحرب وتحرير كافه
المناطق الاوكرانيه
والسحب قواته من اوكرانيا فاذا ما فعل ذلك
فهذه الحرب ستنتهي فورا
[موسيقى]
وجهه نظري اعتقد بان كلا الجانبين وبلا
شكل الجانب الاوكراني فاروسيا لديها هذه
الامكانات او الاحتمال النووي وروسيا من
وجهه نظري ليس لديها اي نوال استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
لان هذا ما حصل هناك اي استخدام لاسلحه
نوويه
فسوف تحصل كوارث كبيره وسوف تدان روسيا
عالميا
وبسبب ذلك اعتقد بان روسيا
تجنبت حتى استخدام هذا الخطاب لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
[موسيقى]